[Music]
you know rises on a new day and a new
government when the Sun rises again on
February 1st the European Union and the
United Kingdom will still be the best of
friends we depart from the EU on the
31st of January at that point brexit
will be done it will be over but it's
not really going to be over is it which
is why Boris Johnson probably doesn't
want you watching what's coming up it's
full of experts are we going to explain
why the next phase of brexit is so much
more difficult and the decisions so much
harder that in the last three and a half
years since the referendum now the Prime
Minister has a majority of 80 so MPs
won't stand in his way but there will be
losers as well as winners from the next
phase of brexit which means number 10
probably doesn't want you paying too
much attention to this I think fishing
is going to be the most difficult issue
I was hoping we'd get control of our own
waters any change in that process will
lead to some level of disruption some
level of backlog we are talking about
queues at the border we're talking about
barriers to trades and services going up
overnight
I have heard as many visions as
conservative MPs are spoken to
it's very difficult to know exactly
what's going to happen in Northern
Ireland don't wanna see I returned the
valence to want to see a return to the
bad old days of the past from January
the first next year we start our new
relationship the one we will negotiate
during the next 11 months the transition
period when our old ties remain in place
unchanged after that the process of
bringing everything into and moving
everything out of Britain will get more
complicated we will be outside the
customs union outside the single market
so that would mean there would be
customs checks customs processes between
the UK and the EU on trade which is a
big change from now where there is no no
checks at all I think there will be
problems at ports whatever the outcome
the government is going to have to face
a bit of negative publicity because
there will be log jams tailbacks ports
because actually there will still have
to be checks with Boris Johnson's deal
they will still have to be checks at
ports aiming ham in Lincolnshire
Britain's biggest port now a container
or a trailer comes off one of these
ferries every 60 seconds the building
blocks of the British economy parts from
Volvo and BMW from Germany turn up here
and are on the road 45 minutes later now
whether we get a deal or not more checks
more forms and just be more bottlenecks
places like this it's unfair in a minute
exactly what it'll look like but some of
the potential suggestions would be some
customs documentation that we don't need
to do today once we start slowing that
supply chain downs any friction that
adds cost and unfortunately that cost is
what will always be the deciding factor
about whose cargo goes where brexit
causes difficulties for the borders of
the future as well as the borders of the
past meaning Northern Ireland is still
at a crossroads in the next phase of
negotiating this is the capacity peace
lane that separates the merely unionist
and loyal - angle Road so this area
would have saw certainly some of the
worst accesses of the conflict during
the days of the troubles and here he
would have had literally
lately bowels gum gum balls we've just
driven round Schenkel area of Belfast
it's quite clear that there are still
divisions in the community if there were
to be any cane of wiggling of Northern
Ireland's constitutional position within
the context of the United Kingdom then I
fear that we would see the prospect of
widespread political protests and I
think in that context you always have
the potential for that spilling over and
there's something more serious three
years agonizing about the Irish border
which is gonna be a new frontier for the
European Union has probably succeeded in
ensuring that it'll be no more intrusive
than this the change in road markings
and surface between the north and the
south and no return to the kind of
customs posts of the past but a solution
only exists on paper and a piss leave
Northern Ireland with one foot inside
the European Union they're the only
place in the entire world that is both
in the UK customs union honored on a
legal basis which means that they will
everyone in Northern Ireland financial
services firms anybody defence air boss
whoever happens to be they will benefit
the challenge on brexit has always been
if you ended up with a solution where
you have a border on the island violent
that is unacceptable to one community
and if you have a border down the IRC
that is a real is unacceptable to the
identity of unis there are warnings from
paramilitary groups that there could be
civil disobedience or worse from the
divisions created by Boris Johnson's
brexit deal between the mainland Great
Britain and Northern Ireland how
seriously should we take those we are 22
years on from the agreement if it takes
you 22 years to transition away from
violence then you're not interested in
peace and you're not interested in the
political process you're just a thug
brexit is about security and identity
but the next phase is so hard because
he'd also in
haggling over one particular industry in
decline
fish is certainly an issue that some
member states are very very clear that
they want to figure in any basic deal
and that they would be very unwilling to
sign up to anything that hadn't you know
negotiated and found an agreement on
that and why is that that's partly
because 33 percent of fish stock from
from the U is actually we think comes
from British waters but also because
actually you know French fishermen de
Nutrition I've been fishing feed
centuries in British waters I'm
third-generation fisherman I've been
fishing for 50 years and enjoyed
probably the first 25 years a lot more
than IV the second 25 we've had to
change our fishery because there's just
the cod stocks in the channel just
disappeared we've totally lost control
of what goes on in our waters we've got
the real poor deal I'm sure the
Europeans will want to just keep it
exactly as it is now and have just as
much access to our waters why should
fishing if it benefits such a small
number of people get as it were special
protection if that could be at the
expense of other things
I think it's pretty easy for anybody
alignment to see the position we've come
to be in one of the first issues to be
negotiated and all kind of set the tone
for the debate and in terms of
presenting to the public what's been
achieved
this is a really key one to get right
there could be room for compromise but
just not in the time that's available it
takes a lot of time to work out those
are the challenges but what are we
asking for
the language of trade deals feels almost
designed to be impenetrable but
including it is key to discovering what
will happen when the EU and the UK slug
it out again in round two listen to what
Europe's top official wants from us in
your speech you've suggested that we
could be on track for a zero tariff zero
quota deal what kind of obligations
might Britain have to adhere to to get
that or were you simply offering that
here today zero quota zero tariffs zero
damping means level playing field that
phrase level playing field get used to
it
all it means is Europe trying to make
sure we stick roughly to their rules on
things like public subsidy workers
rights in the environment in exchange
for this tariff free deal if Boris
Johnson wants to secure an agreement
with Europe that does not frankly rep
the UK economy and large sectors of the
UK economy he will have to agree to a
high alignment model a model where the
government is not really able to diverge
that means keeping things the same as
they are at the moment across other EU
countries rather than diverging or
choosing to set different rules Boris
Johnson isn't keen at the moment they
the day one impact would look very
similar to all of the forecasts for
having if we were to have left the EU
without a deal in place whatsoever we
are talking about queues at the border
we're talking about vast degrees of
uncertainty just months ago the prospect
of No Deal triggered the biggest
political and constitutional crisis of
the modern age but could the government
choose something not dissimilar others
reject such pessimism if the EU says to
us
for example we only will let you have
more taxes if you harmonize completely
with our regulations we should point out
to them that in the case of New Zealand
they've agreed a meat products agreement
in Australia in the beef industry they
have two lines of beef that they produce
one for the closed EU market the closed
loop EU market and one for
the rest of the world both sides stake
out their positions next week talk start
within a month brace for theatrics where
no can mean yes immovable deadlines can
vanish and everyone will declare victory
at all costs but remember there will be
no way to dress up the legal text which
will take center stage at the end
Sam coats Sky News